pour en parler à mes côtés la Mireille
Michelle au lagaille bonjour ancien
commandant de l'école navale et ancien
commandant du port hélicoptère Jeanne
d'Arc merci d'être avec nous amiral a un
drone qui donc mène une mission contre
une base celle d'Engels en territoire US
est à 600 km de la frontière ukrainienne
pour pouvoir montrer à quel point
effectivement on est à l'intérieur du
territoire rue cette même base
d'ailleurs qui avait été frappé toujours
par un drone le 6 décembre dernier que
cherche à faire l'Ukraine est-ce un
geste désespéré de leur peur ou bien
tout simplement une manœuvre de la
propagande russe de leur en attribut la
paternité écoutez ça ne me paraît pas du
tout désespéré ça me paraît même quelque
chose de très construit puisque vous
avez vu que depuis un certain temps les
lignes rouges qu'avaient en principe
établi la Russie son franchit l'usine
après les autres attaquent sur les
Crimée à Sébastopol par exemple qui fait
que les sous-marins russes sont partis à
nos disques attaquent sur nos disques
également quelques bâtiments touchés et
puis ensuite pour la deuxième fois
attaque de drone en tout cas
à une très longue distance quand même de
l'Ukraine et cela d'une façon un peu
systématique mais pas trop intense ce
qui fait qu'avec très peu de moyens en
quelque sorte l'Ukraine peut modifier à
la fois la répartition des bâtiments
puisque les sous-marins ont quitté
Sébastopol et puis aussi mobiliser une
très grande quantité de moyens russes
pour protéger tout ce qui est dans le
rayon d'action de ces de ces drones
ukrainiens et ça si vous voulez ça ça
pèse énormément ce qui fait que vous
avez maintenant toute une région à peu
près 600 km de là de la frontière
ukrainienne enfin au maximum qui est
maintenant presque en zone de guerre en
zone de guerre car les Ukrainiens même
s'ils ne le revendiquent pas et
ukrainiens font peser une menace sur ces
régions là la Russie doit donc mobiliser
davantage de moyens qu'elle ne le
souhaiterait absolument et cela même est
une une tactique qui est tout à fait
remarquable puisque avec très très peu
de moyens donc peut-être deux drones
voyez cette façon-là ils mobilise
quelquefois des milliers de personnels
de jours de nuit tout un réseau de
radars etc donc la mise en oeuvre d'une
grande partie de l'armée russe dans les
500 km autour de l'Ukraine l'Ukraine qui
fait aussi la démonstration de sa
capacité à tromper la défense entière
aérienne russe alors tout à fait
d'ailleurs quand nous voyons qu'il y a
trois techniciens russes blessés sur la
base par les débris semble-t-il de ce
drone ça paraît un peu étonnant ce
serait plutôt le drone lui-même qui qui
a explosé et et d'une certaine façon
c'est avec des drones d'origine russe
modifiés ce sont des tipollets qui font
ils laissent filtrer si vous voulez même
s'il le revendique pas le revendique pas
cette attaque il laisse filtrer le fait
que ce sont des drones de fabrication
ruisseaux ukrainienne modifiée par les
Ukrainiens car ils sont très forts dans
la modification et ils ont une il faut
savoir qu'ils ont quand même de tout le
temps une industrie spatiale et
aérospatiale qui était de très grande
qualité donc maintenant il montre qu'ils
ont la possibilité la capacité sans que
les États-Unis et les États occidentaux
ne soient le plus à toi désigné comme
kobelligérant l'Ukraine qui aujourd'hui
même fait également cette demande qui
peut paraître surprenante elle réclame
l'exclusion de la Russie non seulement
du Conseil de sécurité le num est même
plus largement des Nations Unies
elles-mêmes la Russie qui jusqu'à
présent a fait usage systématiquement de
son droit de veto pour empêcher toute
résolution à son encontre et pour
notamment faire la lumière sur les
crimes de guerre en Ukraine je dirais
que c'est de bonne guerre de
communication c'est de bonne guerre même
sur la place internationale puisque
Poutine par exemple réclame des
négociations à ces conditions
c'est-à-dire je garde le territoire etc
donc des choses absolument
vraisemblables de la même façon
l'Ukraine s'inscrit dans ce même récit
qui est d'affrontement improbable ou
voire même impossible puisque pour que
le Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU pour que
la Russie en soit exclue il faudrait que
le Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU lui-même
en soit d'accord y compris la Russie
donc voyez qu'il n'y a absolument aucune
au toutes les chances pour que cela
arrive alors quel objectif ah mais
l'objectif c'est quand même de continuer
à mettre de façon continue de façon
permanente la Russie en accusation
l'Ukraine demande l'établissement d'un
tribunal spécial l'Ukraine demande
grosso modo à ce que la Russie soit mise
au bancs de l'ONU donc l'Ukraine
poursuit si vous voulez cette cette
politique d'influence aux yeux du monde
pour que de plus en plus de gens
puissent éventuellement considérer la
Russie comme une véritable agresseur
agresseur avec crime de guerre etc alors
qu'un certain nombre de pays jusqu'à
présent ce sont abstenus de la commande
de la condamnée que même certains
d'entre eux 5 pour être plus précis leur
ont apporté lui ont apporté son soutien
merci amiral Michel hola voilà ce qu'on
pouvait dire donc de cette attaque
ukrainienne un drone ukrainien contre
une base en Russie